[Música]
450 grandes bancos que manejan activos
por 130 billones de dólares es decir
alrededor del 40 por ciento del capital
del mundo se comprometieron a financiar
el plan para poner fin a las emisiones
de carbono este es uno de los resultados
de la cob 26
está cada vez más apretado uno de los
resultados de la jornada electoral de
ayer en eeuu el demócrata bill murphy
están menos de un punto por encima del
republicano ya sea tarelli para la
gobernación de nueva jersey los
demócratas ya habían sufrido un revés
con su derrota en virginia
y en francia el senegalés mohammed sarr
ganó el premio goncourt este es el
galardón más prestigioso de la
literatura francesa el autor se
convirtió además en el primer africano
subsahariano en ganar este premio
bienvenidos a las noticias de france 24
yo soy maría clara calle y es un gusto
saludarlos esta tarde
comencemos con la noticia del día de la
cob 26 las grandes instituciones
privadas de crédito de 45 países se
comprometieron a financiar la
descarbonización mundial para mitad de
siglo los 450 bancos manejan un
patrimonio de 130 millones de dólares
entre las entidades están hsbc el banco
santander deutsche bank y morgan y
bancolombia entre otras grandes
entidades financieras
y mientras los bancos debatirán ese
compromiso adentro de la cob 26 en las
calles de glasgow indígenas de varios
países marcharon para concientizar a la
gente sobre el rol de los pueblos
indígenas en la lucha contra el cambio
climático y la amenaza que hay en sus
tierras ancestrales algunos de los
manifestantes se han quejado de la mala
gestión de los gobiernos de sus países
para proteger lo que ellos consideran
como áreas sagradas el informe es de
andrea amaya
ellos también están presentes en la cob
26 quieren que el mundo sepa que sus
tierras están amenazadas muchos
indígenas son escépticos a las promesas
de los gobiernos de sus países de
proteger sus tierras utilizadas para
actividades extractivistas
recibe más acaba de hablar el presidente
del ecuador habla de la protección del
cambio climático que el ecuador está
tiene su diversidad muy grande pero es
con una mentira porque la verdad no yo
conozco desde la comunidad de hemos
venido desde el territorio y hemos visto
a hoy en día los gobiernos tienen su
plan de sacar el petróleo
otro indígena dice estar preocupado por
la contaminación de las vías fluviales
donde él y su familia viven en chile
en muy poco tiempo en los últimos 100
200 años la gente ha estado explorando
la profundidad de lugares que pensábamos
que aún estaban por descubrir había
personas cuidando esas tierras y ahora
están poniendo minas allí extrayendo el
litio y cosas que nos impiden seguir
viviendo allí en la cumbre climática los
líderes mundiales y jefes de estado se
comprometieron a proteger las
comunidades indígenas y las selvas
tropicales invirtiendo millonarias sumas
dinero con fondos públicos y privados
además para disminuir la deforestación
en esta década países que representan
más del 85% de los bosques del mundo se
comprometieron a detenerla entre ellos
varios de américa latina como brasil
colombia y perú sin embargo los
indígenas no están seguros de que estos
planes se vayan a cumplir y aseguran que
una vez implementadas las nuevas
promesas habrá que ver el impacto total
al margen de esta cumbre de la onu
contra el cambio climático salieron a la
luz unas imágenes del mar muerto que
revelan que es cada vez más pequeño
todos los años esta masa de agua que
queda en pleno desierto entre israel y
cisjordania retrocede cerca de un metro
y entre más se encoge más cráter es
dejado a su paso algunos de ellos tienen
10 metros de profundidad el mar muerto
ya ha perdido un tercio de su superficie
desde los años 60
hacemos ahora a eeuu que ayer celebró
elecciones locales en el estado de nueva
yersey todavía no se conoce quién es el
ganador con el 89% de los votos
reportados el demócrata phil murphy
están menos de un punto por encima del
republicano jacques y atar el y sin
embargo los republicanos ganaron en
varios lugares donde los demócratas
solían salir victoriosos como virginia
donde glenio kings fue elegido como
nuevo gobernador del estado por eso
estos comicios suponen un revés para el
presidente joe by de nuevo el mandatario
dijo que su partido demócrata debe
trabajar más para los estadounidenses y
dijo que no creía que la aprobación de
su agenda legislativa hubiera cambiado
los resultados según él era una elección
contra trump escuchemos sus palabras
bueno creo que debimos haberlo aprobado
antes de las elecciones
pero no sé si hubiera podido cambiar el
pensamiento de los conservadores a los
votantes de trump pero tal vez name y
mailing hablemos ahora de américa latina
el ex presidente argentino mauricio
macri acudió a la citación judicial en
la ciudad bonaerense de dolores para
declarar en un caso de presunto
espionaje el ex mandatario aseguró que
es inocente y su defensa alegó que el
mandatario ni espía me ordenó espiar a
los familiares de las víctimas del
submarino san juan- de la armada que fue
hallado hundido en el 2018
y los militares de perú podrán patrullar
junto a la policía en las ciudades de
lima y callao así lo autorizó el
gobierno de pedro castillo ante el
aumento significativo de la delincuencia
en los últimos meses aunque la
administración dice que es para asegurar
el control y mantener el orden muchos
peruanos están preocupados por la medida
temen que se violen sus derechos en el
proceso amnistía internacional y human
rightswatch rechazaron la resolución
presidencial y advirtieron que los
soldados están entrenados para la guerra
y no para el control del orden público
y la corte penal internacional abrirá
una investigación formal contra
venezuela' el fiscal de la cpi karim
camps hizo el anuncio en medio de su
viaje de tres días en caracas la corte
tenía un examen preliminar desde 2018 y
ahora decidió pasar a la siguiente fase
comenzando una investigación la cpi
analiza presuntos delitos del estado al
utilizar fuerza para dispersar las
manifestaciones antigubernamentales de
2017 el presidente nicolás maduro
respondió que respeta la decisión de
abrir una investigación pero que no la
comparte
y las autoridades sanitarias de eeuu
autorizaron la vacuna de facer contra el
cob y 19 para los niños mayores de 5
años sin embargo la dosis que se
suministra a los más pequeños es sólo
una tercera parte de la cantidad de
usada para adolescentes y adultos
entre aplausos de sus amigos karim de 6
años recibe su primera dosis de la
vacuna contra el cob y 19 como el 28
millones de estadounidenses de entre 5 y
11 años ya son elegibles para recibir el
fármaco the fighter
realmente no hace daño pero háganlo por
el bien de eeuu porque esto es ayudar a
eeuu y al mundo y que la vida sea mejor
para todas y cada una de las personas
del planeta
las autoridades aprobaron el fármaco
para los pequeños el martes alegando que
el riesgo de efectos secundarios graves
es menor en los niños además el virus
tiene fuertes impactos en la salud
mental de la población infantil y agravó
las desigualdades en el acceso a la
educación la vacuna también se aplica en
dos dosis con tres semanas de diferencia
entre cada una pero la cantidad aplicada
es sólo una tercera parte de la usada
para adolescentes y niños un estudio
reciente de los centros de control y
prevención de enfermedades señala que de
entre mil padres el 57% declaro que
vacunar a sus hijos
[Música]
creo completamente en la vacuna en la
ciencia he leído artículos donde
explican que los beneficios superan los
posibles efectos secundarios
sin embargo algunos padres discrepan la
principal preocupación es el riesgo de
inflamación del corazón detectado en
adolescentes y jóvenes después de
vacunarse con facer o modernas
no creo que ningún padre deba poner esto
en el cuerpo de sus hijos en eeuu más de
8.300 personas de entre 5 y 11 años han
sido hospitalizadas por kobe 19 de entre
las cuales un tercio precisó cuidados
intensivos según los datos del gobierno
el gobierno colombiano exigirá a la
población una prueba de vacunación
contra el cob y 19 en todo el país el
documento será obligatorio a partir del
16 de noviembre así lo confirmó el
presidente colombiano iván duque quien
está de visita en parís para reunirse
con su homólogo francés emmanuel mayor
andrea vaya tiene los detalles de la
decisión
colombia endurece las medidas para
controlar el hobbit 19 el presidente
iván duque confirmó desde parís que una
prueba de vacunación contra el
coronavirus era obligatoria para los
mayores de edad
la decisión aplica para mayores de 18
años desde el 16 de noviembre se exigirá
al menos una dosis pero en diciembre se
pedirá el esquema completo de vacunación
la medida aplicará para eventos
presenciales de carácter público o
privado que impliquen asistencia masiva
como en bares cines discotecas casinos
iglesias museos entre otros la decisión
busca establecer que sectores de la
población ya han sido inoculados ya que
muchos ciudadanos salieron de colombia a
vacunarse en el extranjero entretanto
desde el 31 de octubre niños y niñas
entre los 3 y los 11 años empezaron a
ser vacunados con el biológico del
laboratorio chino sinovac
esta vacunación tiene varios objetivos
el primero proteger la vida de nuestros
niños de 3 a 11 años que si bien tienen
efectos menores tienen igualmente
riesgos pero también proteger a la
población de la edad los niños
en los adultos todos podemos hacer
cuadros síntomas sintomáticos y ser
transmisores la vacuna minimiza ese
riesgo del contagio según el ministerio
de salud colombiano tan solo el fin de
semana más de 22 mil niños en el país
fueron vacunados contra el sars cop 2 lo
que impulsará su regreso a las aulas
colombia superó el martes la barrera de
los 5 millones de contagiados y registra
más de 127 mil muertes y aunque en los
meses de junio y julio registró tasas
bajas de contagios diarios que hicieron
pensar en el fin de la pandemia en el
instituto nacional de salud de advirtió
que no es el momento de bajar la guardia
ya que las nuevas variantes del virus
siguen circulando
digamos con un breve recorrido por las
noticias del cob y 19 en el mundo
el gobierno chino estaría preparándose
para decretar nuevos confinamientos por
lo que le pidió a las familias que se
abastezcan de alimentos y otros
artículos esenciales diarios en los
últimos días se han reportado cifras
récord de nuevos contagios de kobe 19
la organización mundial de la salud
aprobó la vacuna contra el cob y 19
kóvacs in de india es producida por la
farmacéutica barata baile el organismo
la incluyó en la lista de uso de
emergencia esto permite que la dosis sea
aceptada como una vacuna válida en
muchos países
la onu advirtió que podrían aumentar los
contagios y muertes por vih en áfrica
central y occidental esto por la
interrupción y el colapso de los
servicios sanitarios a causa de la
pandemia del cob y 19 sólo el año pasado
cerca de 200.000 personas se contagiaron
de vih en la región
en otras noticias africanas argelia
afirma que tres de sus ciudadanos
murieron en el bombardeo que marruecos
propinó en la zona fronteriza entre
mauritaria y el sáhara occidental' el
gobierno argelino advirtió que este
hecho no quedará impune las relaciones
de los países rivales de áfrica se han
deteriorado por su postura frente a una
zona en disputa y es que argelia es el
anfitrión y principal partidario del
frente polisario que busca la
independencia del sahara occidental
mientras que marruecos cataloga como
propio este territorio el gobierno
marroquí no se ha pronunciado todavía
sobre el bombardeo
y terminamos en francia el senegalés
mohammed sarr ganó el premio goncourt
este es el galardón más prestigioso de
la literatura francesa su novela la
memoria más secreta de los hombres lo
puso como el favorito de la crítica
entre todos los nominados este escritor
de 31 años es el primer africano
subsahariano en ganar el premio
conozcamos un poco más de este autor en
el siguiente informe
casi avergonzado mohamed vulgar se asoma
en el balcón del restaurante duro para
recibir el premio con court el
reconocimiento literario francés más
importante por su cuarta novela el
recuerdo más secreto de los hombres
de la academia goncourt envía una señal
muy fuerte creo que a muchas personas en
primer lugar al medio literario francés
por supuesto pero también a todos los
círculos literarios del mundo francófono
azul y medio literal de l'expansion
conforme a sus 31 años el escritor
senegalés es uno de los receptores más
jóvenes del premio y el primero de
áfrica sub-sahariana a través del
teléfono su padre no oculta la emoción
tengo un sentimiento enorme de
satisfacción y orgullo y todo lo que
puedas imaginar para describir una
dedicación extrema
la obra narra la fascinación de un joven
escritor por una novela africana de
ficción publicada en la década de 1930 y
el efímero ascenso de su autor acusado
de plagio antes de hundirse en el olvido
una historia polifónica donde se mezclan
los géneros homenaje al poder de la
creación literaria que buscar nunca deja
de cuestionar nos la literatura
y creo que la literatura es un acertijo
y una pregunta que el deseo de escribir
es un acertijo y una pregunta hay
escritores que saben desde temprano por
qué quieren convertirse en escritores y
que saben exactamente cuándo se
convertirán en escritores no sé cuando
quise convertirme en escritor ni
siquiera estoy seguro todavía que
el joven recibirá un cheque de diez
euros como premio y la promesa de miles
de ventas por su trabajo
con esta noticia del premio goncourt
terminamos nuestra emisión informativa
ustedes sigan conectados con nuestra
señal de televisión y también con
nuestra página web france24 puntocom los
espero para más información
[Música]